foreign
welcome to Simply learn today's video
will compare and contrast artificial
intelligence deep learning machine
learning and data science but before we
get started consider subscribing to
simplylearn's YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon that way you'll be the
first to get notified when we post
similar content before moving on let me
ask you two interesting queries
which among the following is not a
branch of artificial intelligence data
analysis machine learning deep learning
neural networks and the second query is
what is the main difference between
machine learning and deep learning
please leave your answer in the comments
section below and stay tuned to get the
answer
first we will unwrap deep learning deep
learning was first introduced in the
1940s deep learning did not develop
suddenly it developed slowly and
steadily over seven decades many Theses
and discoveries were made on deep
learning from the 1940s to 2000 thanks
to companies like Facebook and Google
the term deep learning has gained
popularity and may give the perception
that it is a relatively New Concept deep
learning can be considered as a type of
machine learning and artificial
intelligence or AI that imitates how
humans gain certain types of knowledge
deep learning includes statistics and
predictive modeling deep learning makes
processes quicker and simpler which is
advantageous to data scientists to
gather analyze and interpret massive
amounts of data having the fundamentals
discussed let's move into the different
types of deep learning neural networks
are the main component of deep learning
but neural networks comprise three main
types which contain artificial neural
networks or an
convolution neural networks or CNN and
recurrent neural networks or RNN
artificial neural networks are inspired
biologically by the animal brain
convolutional neural networks surpass
other neural networks when given inputs
such as images Voice or audio it
analyzes images by processing data
recurrent neural networks uses
sequential data or series of data
convolutional neural networks and
recurrent neural networks are used in
natural language processes speech
recognition image recognition and many
more machine learning the evolution of
ml started with the mathematical
modeling of neural networks that served
as the basis for the invention of
machine learning in 1943 neuroscientist
Warren McCulloch and logician Walter
Pitts attempted to quantitatively map
out how humans make decisions and carry
out thinking processes therefore the
term machine learning is not new machine
learning is a branch of artificial
intelligence and computer science that
uses data and algorithms to imitate how
humans learn gradually increasing the
system's accuracy there are three types
of machine learning which include
supervised learning what is supervised
learning well here machines are trained
using label data machines predict output
based on this data now coming to
unsupervised learning models are not
supervised using a training data set it
is comparable to the learning process
that occurs in the human brain while
learning something new and the third
type of machine learning is
reinforcement learning here the agent
learns from feedback it learns to behave
in a given environment based on actions
and the result of the action this
feature can be observed in robotics
now coming to the evolution of AI the
potential of artificial intelligence
wasn't explored until the 1950s although
the idea has been known for centuries
the term artificial intelligence has
been around for a decade still it wasn't
until British polymath Alan Turing posed
the question of why machines couldn't
use knowledge like humans do to solve
problems and make decisions
we can Define artificial intelligence as
a technique of turning a computer-based
robot to work and act like humans
now let's have a glance at the types of
artificial intelligence
weak AI performs only specific tasks
like Apple Siri Google assistant and
Amazon's Alexa you might have used all
of these Technologies but the types I am
mentioning after this are under
experiment General AI can also be
addressed as artificial general
intelligence it is equivalent to human
intelligence hence an AGI system is
capable of carrying out any task that a
human can
strong AI aspires to build machines that
are indistinguishable from the human
mind
both General and strong AI are
hypothetical right now rigorous research
is going on on this matter there are
many branches of artificial intelligence
which include machine learning deep
learning natural language processing
robotics expert systems fuzzy logic
therefore the correct answer for which
is not a branch of artificial
intelligence is option a data analysis
now that we have covered deep learning
machine learning and artificial
intelligence the final topic is data
science
Concepts like deep learning machine
learning and artificial intelligence can
be considered a subset of data science
let us cover the evolution of data
science the phrase data science was
coined in the early 1960s to
characterize a new profession that would
enable the comprehension and Analysis of
the massive volumes of data being
gathered at the time
since its Beginnings data science has
expanded to incorporate ideas and
methods from other fields including
artificial intelligence machine learning
deep learning and so forth data science
can be defined as the domain of study
that handles vast volumes of data using
modern tools and techniques to find
unseen patterns derive meaningful
information and make business decisions
therefore data science comprises machine
learning artificial intelligence and
deep learning I hope this was helpful
thank you for watching and happy
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here